[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
round one of the Fall Classic here in
st. Louis in the a group Canadian Eric
Hanson had the seventh rank of norway's
you and Ludvig hammer on lock the chess
bra says that the rust is gone
Group B all decisive games including
Stevens earth hanging a bishop or
hanging mate he had to resign to Hannes
taboos e'en with such an even field
round 2 starts now 20 international
chess professionals compete in st. Louis
as US chess champs calm presents the
second annual fall chess classic
you are looking live once again at the
world-famous boardroom tournament hall
in st. Louis
it's the chess club and these players
after round one have shown that they are
not playing around this is serious
business
come on into the studio and take off
your shoes join us for a while hello
chess fans my name is Ben Simon and I'm
joined as always by international master
and famous streamer Eric Rosen
Eric we had a lot of fun yesterday and
today was not gonna be any different
it's true we had a lot of decisive games
yesterday I think players were the
overcoming the first round nerves
overcoming some jetlag overcoming
sickness and because of that I think a
lot of lot of mistakes were made and if
the the games continued to be this
entertaining I think we're gonna have a
fun event
yeah absolutely let's take a look at the
standings in Group A after just one
round and we had a couple of decisive
games and then we had three draws Eric
what's your assessment of the standings
thus far well I mean Alexei dray of and
Eric Hansen getting off - very good
starts Eric Hansen especially being
inactive before the only bid winning
with the black pieces yesterday got
against hammer just can't ask for a
better start the nets so we'll see if
Eric and Alexei can keep up the momentum
of course we still have a good number of
players with starting solid with half a
points so at this point I mean the
tournament is still up for grabs for
anyone and in Group B if you were
watching on us chess champs calm you saw
all those meters were white or black
there was no in between
100% decisive games all ones and zeroes
okay so let's take a look at the
tournament format this is a two field
round-robin event we have the a group
and we have the B group as we said the
time control is 90 minutes for 40 moves
and then after both players complete 40
they have 30 minutes added onto each
clock for the remainder of the game
because there is a 30 second increment
from move number one all of the players
must take notation from beginning to end
and there is a 30 move draw rule in
effect which means that the players
cannot agree to a draw until after
blacks thirtieth move now of course
exceptions can be made to that whenever
there's a three-fold repetition or
something of that nature but the players
can't just outward I agree - that's
right we haven't seen that yet with a
three-fold repetition occurring before
move 30 we did see a very quick draw
yesterday between Bruges and Kobe and
Ray Robson where all the pieces came off
the board think they drew exactly on
move 30 but apart from that I mean we're
gonna see hopefully a lot more fighting
games absolutely and I'm sure we will
let's take a look at the tournament
schedule now we are entering into a
stretch of consistency each day the
rounds begin at 1:00 p.m. and we are on
the air two and a half hours after 1
p.m.
all these are Central Time so 3:30 p.m.
we'll be with you every day until next
Wednesday and then the final day we
start a little bit early to make room
for playoffs if we need them because
there can only be one in each field we
know this and along the way we would
love to talk to you we'd love to hear
from you on social media so on the
YouTube chat we'll be looking for your
questions and comments on Twitch I
believe that our control room is looking
at twitch as well we are streaming live
there and join the conversation
everywhere with hashtag fall chess
classic so this is more interactive than
we've ever been before Eric and I love
it I do too and hopefully it's great for
the fans if you guys have questions
don't be scared to make your voice heard
in the chats and we're always open to
feedback too so hopefully we will get
some nice engagement throughout this
event absolutely now these games started
2 and a half hours ago they're still all
in progress here are the pairings for
group a round two we have the hammer
taking on Alexei dray of Ray Robson
versus your EKU's evolve Sethuraman
taking on varoujan Akopian Lazaro
bruising vs. daro spirits and we have
the key matchup in Group A
that's right the notorious chest bra
Eric Hansen taking on Alexander
Lenderman and yesterday when I was
rewatching the the YouTube chat replay a
lot of people were saying go Eric
go Eric and I got really excited I
thought they were talking about me and
then I realized they're probably talking
about Eric Hansen you're just streaming
so good man that's true going but they
have a very heated game under way we
should go ahead and take a look at
what's happening I want to note
straightaway that Eric Hansen is
currently in pretty severe time pressure
having less than 10 minutes now I do
want to go through just what happened in
the opening as came from a caro-kann to
nice attack which I know Lenderman does
specialize in the caro-kann and a very
peculiar remove was seen on move six for
black Bishop to e6 not something you see
every day from my experience the main
move is usually Queen to d5 going for an
immediate Queen trade after Bishop e6
play it was a bit strange Hansen decided
to fianchetto his Queen side Bishop and
then both players began improving their
pieces and then I think lunderman
realized his bishop was not so great on
e6 he improved it by placing it on f5
then the game continued in a bit more
normal fashion both players just
continuing developments castling their
Kings I do want to zoom forward here and
take a look at what transpired because
box Queen really entered the the heart
of White's territory landing on g3 and
the combination of Queen and Knights
also this Bishop protecting the knight
from age 7 it seems like Bach has some
interesting coordination here now white
does have very nice central control but
the coordination of box pieces is a bit
tricky there's a lot of squares in
White's territory controlled by the Bach
pieces not to mention this somewhat
annoying pin on the third-ranked this
Bishop cannot move allowing the Queen on
e3 to be captured so going forward here
at rook 88 93 Bishop e7
and then somewhat strange retreating
move Knight to c1 but clearly planning
to play this activating 92 to chase the
black Queen away so the Queen retreated
to g6 92 93 the Knights got traded the
Queen returns to g3 and then very
explosive move by Hansen pawn d5 which
seems like it's going to complicate a
lot of things now there's a lot of
tension in the center there's lots of
lots of different captures that that can
consider being black has three attackers
on d5 White has three defenders so it's
possible that we will see some
liquidation now that I'm realizing
actually the the bishop is still pinned
so I'm curious what what the
calculations will be we should also know
that this pawn on e6 is is pinned as
well so there's a few pins happening in
the position visually I do like this
move d5 but I do not like Eric's time
situation and we can see him looks like
maybe one more move a few more moves
have been played actually any update the
current position after d5 there was a
trade and then Bishop to c2 and we can
see Eric there is kind of hovering over
the board Lenderman standing up but now
sitting down so I'm sure both players
are be intently focused for the moves to
come they do have 15 moves to make until
time control but you rather have black
in this situation it's a good question
um I mean if I was black and I had the
time advantage absolutely yes I mean I I
really like situations where my
opponents low on time and then I have
enough time to kind of sit back relax
and also calculate when the position
calls for it I keep in mind these
players do have a 30-second increment we
were looking at this game right before
we went on the air and the time deficit
was even greater significantly greater
actually and so it has evened out a
little bit but that's saying something
because there's still 35 minutes
separating these players Eric is not
comfortable by any means but let's see
if he can work his way through this
okay and now we turn our attention over
to Group B let's take a look at the
games in progress for the pairings first
of all we have eight grandmasters in
this field action genre takes on
Christopher you who's looking for norms
city in this tournament
Conrad Holt versus L Shaun more idea
body sergey as her of taking on danish
boorish brandon jacobson versus Stephens
irk and our key matchup for droopy yeah
that's right we have the two two winners
yesterday Havana's kuboos Ian and
ostrich Iram competing to potentially
take sole lead in the tournament if
either player wins
they will stay perfect I do want to take
a look at the current current position I
want to start a few moves back because
about half hour ago it was a pretty slow
maneuvering game coming from a
relatively quiet variation of the ready
opening both players were kind of
minding their own business and then
right around move 24 with B takes e5
this is where it seems like fireworks
begin to happen the pawns got traded the
knight plants itself on d5 the Knights
got traded and then from this moment
forward it seems like White has some
nice initiative white is now attacking
the knight on c6 the knight was forced
to move away to somewhat sad square on
85 and then I really like the move by
Koo Busey and here at pawn to c4 just
unleashing this quite monstrous Bishop
on a1 and now there's two attackers
against upon an e5 there's only one
defender being the Queen on e7 and
usually Queens and chefs do not like to
be the the sole defender and this
provoked
Jayram to play somewhat sad move pawn f6
as I was saying yesterday this move is
not a favorite of been fine gold by any
means and now after C take d5 seems like
white is continuing the initiative and I
should point out here that once white
captures this pawn there's a very sneaky
tactical threats black cannot take back
without losing the some material smooth
pawn d6
you were spotting that then I'm very
happy it's one of the most powerful
moves in chess to attack your opponent's
Queen and your opponent's king in the
same move this case taking advantage of
the discovered attack along the 8th to
g8 diagonal I don't know if black would
be losing a whole Queen here but it
looks pretty bad I mean Bishop e6 knight
take you six black is is losing material
so after C take b5 ashwin had to play
King f8 removing the King from that
diagonal and it just seems like white
just went up a couple pawns but we
should note this line is still attacked
on g5 black simply took the Knights and
after rook take E 5
I'm counting correctly White has three
pawns for a piece but I don't think this
is a situation where material is too
relevant I mean if we look at White's
activity and initiative I really like
the combination of this double fee and
care though the bishops piercing through
the center of the board combined with
this rook on e5 and blacks King doesn't
have too much shelter and it seems like
the coordination especially at last
moderate pieces I mean the two bishops
off to the side the night off to the
other side seems like box pieces aren't
working together that well here Queen d6
was played and light continues to
optimize the position I would really
have to prefer white in this position I
mean the two rooks doubled up it seems
like perfect harmony for for all of the
white pieces harmony is a good thing it
is now I do want to mention I heard
yesterday from Ashman don't know if too
many people know this but he has a
full-time job he lives in st. Louis he
works I think a nine-to-five job most
weekdays and he went to work at 7 a.m.
this morning worked half the day and
then came to came to the game this
afternoon so he might be a bit more
tired than than his opponent in this
game yeah so we've been billing this as
chess professionals you
some of these guys they're not full-time
chess professionals and the real life
doesn't pause for this tournament it's
really got students who are still going
to school and it's not just this
tournament mini tournaments to support
yourself solely on chess is not a sure
thing for most players so this is a it
adds to the backstory that's for sure it
is it'll be even more impressive as if
Ashman can perform well while working
part time but it's a hard thing to
juggle and from from personal standpoint
when I play in treatments I will
occasionally give online lessons during
events and it can be it can be tiring to
work on the side and focus on the chest
it's a whole juggling act for sure and
let's see what the prizes are for this
event because you know there's more than
just pride and in some cases norms here
$22,000 for group a with the first place
winner walking away with six grand and
remember there will be only one
first-place winner because we will have
playoffs if necessary and in Group B
fourteen thousand dollar prize fund four
thousand dollars for the first place
winner same story as with regards to
playoffs as Group A okay so let's get
into the games besides the key matchups
and first one that catches my eye
area.the hammers in trouble for the
second day in a row he might lose this
against Alexi dray of let's jump to that
game I see the position and it looks
quite graphic I mean for the younger
viewers watching the light when I close
your eyes just for a moment here I mean
this King on d2 not the safest piece it
seems like White's pieces are just
completely out of play we were not
looking at this game earlier so I'm just
curious how they reached such a scary
looking position for whites so let's go
back and I believe it came from a
caro-kann go back all the way I'll give
a little bit of commentary in the
opening here now I will say I've played
rave before and he's a very predictable
predictable player in the opening he
sticks usually to
reporter he's known for being a
caro-kann specialist and it seems like
hammer tried to out prepare him or maybe
prepare a tricky line but I mean even
from this position I I like the the
start of the game black just having two
pieces developed and White's entire back
row being completely undeveloped going
forward here Knight f3 Queen to see 794
and this just looks like a pawn
sacrifice leaving the e5 pawn undefended
Queen take e5 I'm just a bit curious
about Reyes expression they're leaning
back and putting his hands on on his
face but okay he just seems to be
getting in the zone we see what happens
here at Bishop to e3 so White's prop
sacrifice a pawn to accelerate the
development after 97 and Queen to b3
Queen c7 might to b5 you know what this
reminds me of it's very similar to a
variation in the French defense which I
actually gave a lecture on just last
week the the Milner Barre variation
where white gives away both Center pawns
from very early on but usually likes to
get this this immediate activity
especially with the knight coming to d5
and harassing the black Queen so let's
go forward here and see how the game
unfolded because here White House
initiative but we'll see how drea
potentially neutralizes a play castling
kingside
maybe not the the easiest move to play
allowing Knight c7 seems like drea VA's
now now the one sacrificing bat material
so try and get perhaps some initiative
for himself and now we see pawn to e5
actually very strange move to give away
a center pawn by like this decision
because sometimes when you give away
pawns you open files and with the
absence of the the e5 pawn especially
after Bishop takes five the e-file is
now completely Palmas meaning that if a
rook ever comes to you
then white skein could be in danger
also the bishop is now a target on e5 so
Nike c6 was played hitting the bishop
bishop retreats to to g3 and now the
rook is saved this is actually a very
clever sequence to save the rook from
being captured on eight to create
initiative against a bishop and after
Queen take d7 it is a strange position
I mean white's knight is pinned on c7
but it is it it is defended twice I mean
it's defended by the bishop on g3 the
Queen on b7 very hard to decipher what's
going on here we should point out that
white is still up a pawn it's going
forward here rook to b8 Queen a6 Brooke
take me to so black winds up on back and
going forward even more from here it
seems like King safety is becoming a
more relevant factor I mean boxing is
safely tucked away on g8 and the king is
still uncle doni e1 and black continues
initiative here Brooke take d5 Knight
takes e5 Queen e6 very nice move
normally when you're checked on a 1 you
would like to find a piece to block the
check but in this case there's nothing
to luck I mean White's pieces this Queen
on a3 the knight on d5 the bishop on g3
they're all out of plate or they're not
really coordinating that well and this
is where we see the King being forced to
give away its casting rights King Ditu
Queenie for rook H to be one I think a
few more moves have been played maybe
just one more move played pawn h5 and it
seems like Bach is having all the fun
here concede ray of his left his heat
hammer is now the one thinking and again
to point out the time situation hammer
has just over 15 minutes left to make
about 15 moves and he's under serious
pressure I mean there's threats of age
for coming there's the constant concern
of the white king now white is up the
exchange here white does have a rook for
nights but I would much prefer black in
this position
Aleksey drea of looking very good so far
in round number two here we see a group
a action another game in Group A and
that catches my eye
eric is cerumen versus Coby on and take
a look look Akopian was down here
preparing for this game it down here in
the near the studio before round number
two and he goes up right at the last
second and let's see what he has for
Seth Aaron yeah I was actually quite
surprised with a Coby ins opening choice
he played the an opening that you don't
see too often at the highest level he
played the Scandinavian yesterday we
were fattening the possibility of maybe
seeing a Halloween gathered this
tournament which is even more or less
common but I honestly was not expecting
to see a sky Navy in this tournament
well you just talked about the
Scandinavian last week in a lecture I
did part of the I think it was an
amateur openings
it was the amateur openings and and tips
or whatever yeah and I mentioned in the
Cobian game in that lecture there's a US
Championship I think in 2016 that a
Cobian played the Scandinavian against
Viviano Caruana
and it was really interesting kind of
opening battle Fabiano got the best of
him so maybe this wasn't a complete
surprise for a theramin given that
Akopian has played this opening before
now I will say the Scandinavian is a
nice opening to play at lower lower
levels because it's very intuitive and
it's very easy to figure out where all
of the black pieces should go usually
black has a very simple setup combining
this Bishop on g4 down on f6 usually
going for a six Bishop d6 90 d7 and four
players that are just starting out and
that are looking for just a simple
opening against Pawnee for I think this
is a very nice choice given that you can
usually achieve the setup without too
much difficulty but at the highest
levels there are some drawbacks of
playing the Scandinavian
mainly the fact that White's gets more
space with this pawn on d4 and in this
specific variation light is also getting
the bishop pair so sometimes the smaller
advantages are very much valued at the
highest levels now I do want to zoom
forward here because it seems like both
sides are completing developments trying
to improve the position but we do see
this saw it's very nice kind of flank
pawn lunge from Sethuraman pawn g5
kicking the Knights back to e eights
pretty sad square for the Knights and
now White's is continuing to improve and
after Bishop f4 there's a quite annoying
pin and it seems like black is a bit
tied down here the knight is pinned and
the Knights also blocks this Bishop on
f8 from developing so it's it seems to
be like a busy elevator where so many
people are like crammed in the elevator
for black and it's not easy to perhaps
maneuver with so less space and so many
pieces still on the board Eric I have a
result for you in Group B our leader of
Hannah's caboose ian has defeated lounge
aram and we understand we are gonna have
him in the studio in just a moment for
an interview so let's take a look at
that game in the meantime okay we will
come back to the a Cobian game but i was
not expecting to have a decisive result
so soon I mean boo-boos Ian's position
looks good moments ago but I didn't
think it was that good let's go back
from where we last left left off and see
how play unfolded after rook take he
five Queen d6 we saw this very nice
piece coordination from white to rooks
are amazingly placed in the center and
it seems like Ashwin maybe not in the
best form today decided to take this
pawn on a6 does win back material but as
I've said before material does not
always tell the whole story
given that white just seems how the
amazing initiative here
queen bee - very very nice and sneaky
move there might not be a clear
difference between the Queen being on an
a2 or b2 but okay for a strong player we
can see that the queen is now eyeing
this diagonal maybe some ideas of rookie
Savon followed by Queen eight shades
let's go forward here rook to b8 rookie
a check Wow
just seems like just concrete
calculation rook takes Queen h8 King f7
Queen age seven King f8 and Queen take
h8 with with the unstoppable checkmate
next move wherever the king goes Queen
d7 checkmate is coming now I do want to
welcome a special guest in the studio
Havana's go Busey and congratulations on
your second victory in a row were you
expecting to win so quickly
given the kind of slow my third opening
I was worried unhappy because of my
position because I messed up somewhere
but I don't know what exactly was wrong
in my gloomy game asked just try and
click to keep my position more or less
safe but my opponent made one mistake I
think and then I started already to play
for advantage mm-hmm can you take us to
this moment where the key mistake was
made playing some logical moves but
later I was very happy with the position
it seemed pleasant for black know where
is possible like every time I do is
taking or coming with Knight b6 so I
just decided to not to push my pawns and
just hold my position because it's it's
not so bad it's maybe always a passive
but you seem like one of these like kind
of slow grinds where both players kind
of doing their own thing and then then
maybe you're just waiting for some
opportunity the position because I don't
have here H wife was already items like
h5 because here I played this for you
know what idea maybe
place some work engage to Bishop age
trade to try to trade the bishops but I
was not sure I just played a short
because I didn't say any ideas for a
white but here I was I thought that h6
is were a good move because now he's H
wife is never good for white laughter g5
I will lose this pawn somewhere so I
don't know what I was going to play
after h6 honestly and the h5 gives me a
lot of chances now I have the g5 Square
and Black Knights are on the cool side
and usually dislike g45 squares are
being used by night so I thought that
it's already a mistake thank you yeah
I'm trying to imagine here how a plaque
and a Sunday get a night so yeah sure I
can have my nighttime g5 and it will
make some pressure range King said so
yeah here I play tonight if one with the
following idea which happened in again
maybe that was a good like Bishop
different 28 - yeah I really like the
Queen on a to seem like a very useful
because my next one for a 93 and some 95
fun oh I think about some c4 maybe
nothing's actually here but with general
idea to lock the phone on a the bishop
on a one but again so c4 for him for
example a c4 takes Bishop g5 takes and
Bishop e6 interesting maybe you would
play something like 93 my friend might
be six probably well it's not simple
finish maybe blue boy work giving is
better I'm Krishna Bishop on a1 is made
after c4 probably I can place already
for its interesting move so c-44 I
thought
[Music]
seems like this will offering that's it
some chances after the Queenie seven was
a very terrible mistake because now 93
and yeah there's just so much so much
nice alignment here with you after a
couple of moves like I activated all my
pieces 95 and here I believe last
mistake was to take 95 because it's
already after 95 c4 I just I don't know
I don't say any more like so yeah it
seems like a dream come true gas or
yourself oh my bishop on a1 became a may
be the strongest pissed on the board so
I'm gonna type like king maybe the there
was ability a couple of most before not
to take on d5 and play some Queen b7 of
course it's already bad but maybe not so
maybe there are some chances because
after 95 it's I think it's almost lost
yeah I can be difficult when like you
you let the advantage or the kind of
balanced position slip and then
sometimes it leads to this downward
spiral effect because it seems like
that's what happened to him we're just
she mistake snowballs but I was like
super a because a couple of moves before
I was thinking about just to hold my
position here before maybe there are
many options but I decided to take the
pawns yeah I mean it's just seeing it's
visually just crushing for why it's
Lister I can take anywhere in g5 and
have four pawns but I thought so I'm
making good here after a rookie one I
don't know how to hold because Queen B -
maybe they only move to create some
problems for me what c4 because now like
Queen B - it's easy threes coming can
bishops it for a queen a six but I'm
sure it's also winning but I don't know
how exactly I was thinking about like to
take on c4 and play rookie 7 maybe yeah
seems like there's yeah I can take and
play like a 7 even or just try to bring
my queen to d3 maybe Queen b3 or
anyway I think it's winning but maybe
that wasn't so easy as in the game cuz
after Aquino 6 wouldn't be true there
isn't mate
ya seem like a very very instructive
play just in terms of opening up the
position getting your pieces to good
squares after your your win yesterday
you seemed very serious in the studio we
were getting some comments in the chat
that you don't show too much emotion
necessarily when you win is it's just a
matter of keeping a poker face or are
you I'm sure you're pleased with
yourself
[Music]
but I'm satisfied because well I played
a good game I got some bad position in
the opening cut right to hold and later
very nice and what's your strategy for
the rest of the tournament are you gonna
just keep doing what you're doing do you
know who you're playing tomorrow
well I'm concentrated like on every
single game I'm just trying to play a
good chess that's all relaxed well I
will let you go congrats on and two
victories in a row and best of luck in
your next games thank you so I believe
we are going to take a commercial break
and we will be back with more coverage
of the 2018 fall chess Classic stay
tuned
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premiere gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org be
surprised
and we're back welcome back to round two
action of the 2018 fall chess classic my
name is Ben Simon I'm joined by
international master and famed streamer
Eric Rosen Eric there's a lot going on
but let's give due process here we were
looking at set twos winning position
against a Cobian what can we see from
this position if we go back yeah I think
there's a lesson to take away that
Scandinavian might be a somewhat dubious
opening among the highest levels I do
want to go to where we last left off in
the position where white was just
seemingly completely dominating with
with the longer pieces more space after
after this Bishop planted itself ie 5
White is in full domination Bishop is
pinning the the Knights of the Queen
also applying pressure to g7 after Queen
d7 turned out this Bishop on f8 was just
overworked after Knight 86 bishops 86
bishop actually excuse me Ponzi for
first 97 and then Bishop take g7
white just went up seemingly a clean
pawn zooming forward here seems like
White's just managed to keep the
advantage and black is still quite
passive
pawn b3 Rock h8 such a sad move but
perhaps scared of the potential for
Bishop take h7 so white just keeps
improving pollen h4 upon f4 rook de
Yeates and seems like Sethu is taking a
page out of some kind of famous
statement from the chest bras this push
and baby we just start pushing the pawns
I think there's a song on Spotify a
featuring Yasir Sarah Wan yeah that's
called pushin baby
and it's what this position is reminding
me I was just uh King side pawns being
constantly pushed down the board and it
doesn't stop on g6 provoking Khan f6 and
now we see very
defended passage upon on just two
squares away from queening it's gonna be
a valuable asset for light going forward
in the game and just seems like white is
in full cruise control pawn d5 nice
explosive move this reminds me of the
Eric Hansen game we saw this exact law
information various static pawn chain
with two black pawns being able to to
capture on d5
but seems like white now wants to open
the position and create some additional
targets on on blacks Queen side most
notably the Queen is now being unleashed
to target the a7 pawn and this is very
common when you push pawns you open up
lines for your pieces and that's what
we're seeing here the Queen is being
opened up the rook kunshi having more
scope on the D file it might also be
that this bishop wants to wants to come
in someday maybe to e4 but we'll see
we'll see how this unfolded trade on on
d5 occurred and then Queen take a seven
now the black King completely unsafe
here Queen a8 turns out the Queen's just
got traded and white is up upon this
night is just so sad on g7 rook hg8 and
now rook f7 I think one more move was
played pawn to c3 this brings us to the
current position where I mean white just
seems to have a massive advantage really
admire the play by Sephora Mon in this
game really gradually growing his
advantage from the opening having the
two bishops having more space and
putting the clamp down on version of
Cobian who is not an easy player to beat
what would set to his progress be from
here a rook H to d1 looking to put it on
the seventh rank yeah now he is taking
his time here rook ht1 certainly a very
simple and logical move in the position
usually when you're reaching the these n
gain stages you want to look to put both
rooks on the seventh rank I gave a
lecture at the st. Louis chess club just
about you
Rico called pigs on the seventh rank and
they're called pigs because they they
just like to eat everything I don't
necessarily like the name pig but it it
does apply to this position now I do
have to note that a potential blunder
for whites would be a move like rook h3
would be completely shocked if this
happens but at first it looks logical
given that light is simply wanting to
take the pawn but this would allow the
the nasty rook e1 jack
not quite checkmate but it would force
white to give up the bishop so light
does have to be a little bit careful
about back rank ideas so I do like this
move going back ruk d1 may be preparing
rook d7 maybe to start with a 4 and then
go for a rook DD 7 and it seems like
black has just tied down here I mean
this Knights is is a bit stuck on g7 and
I mean the knight could capture on h5
but this g6 pawn is always going to be
supported by the bishop and I mean the
simple idea of a4 and rook d7 seems
quite strong here for whites I'd like to
take a look at another endgame happened
to skip over to group B action Chandra
vs. Chris you and the its there's a
white knight on the board and then it's
all pawns this is a game that we have
not taken a look at yet Christopher you
the youngest player in Group B against
Akshay Andhra one of the youngest
players in Group B and we do see this
material imbalance you can go back just
a few moves we see that white did have
an outside past a pawn which can be
quite strong in many endgame situations
usually in the opening you want to you
want to focus on having your center
pawns but in the end game sometimes the
outside especially passed pawns can be a
lot more valuable and seems likes to
seem like this was the case here
after king f - keenie 795 now there's no
way for back to to saute 7 which will
ultimately lose the bishop pawn g5
played a7 bishop take a 7 and I take a 7
I'm counting material here it seems like
Bach just has one pawn for the Knights
might still be a matter of technique but
I I would expect
Oxshott to win this position without too
much difficulty do you think it's gonna
come soon it could very well come yeah
actually a few more moves have been
played and we should also note that
Christopher u is in very big-time
pressure having just over 2 minutes to
make about five or six more moves king
e5 was played and this brings us to the
current position
seems like white can just plant the
Knights in to d4 and seems like
everything's controlled everything would
be defended for white and then it's just
a matter of how to make progress in
order for a white to win this position
white has to either find some sort of
weakness to targets or just start
advancing the pawns and we might end up
seeing another case of push and baby
where the long-term plan for white might
just be to continue to push the kingside
pawns and light we'll also have time to
perhaps optimize the King bring it to c3
maybe even bring it to d4 at some points
and I think the combination of pushing
the King side pawns and also targeting
this somewhat backward pawn on d5 should
be enough for white to win this game
without too much trouble
action for the win potentially alright
another game we haven't looked at that
may end soon group a it's going to be
yer a coup Zubov looking very good as
black he's taking on Rey Robson one of
the most well known players around here
longtime US Championship competitor
Webster University zone and this may not
be his
day and yeah ray was one of my picks to
to do well in group a he's a good friend
of mine former teammate of mine too
having studied at Webster University but
yeah the position doesn't seem through
promising I do want to go back to an
interesting moment much earlier it came
from a similar offbeat variation of the
Petrov defense where it seemed like race
at the exchange very early with Bishop
take f6 Queen take f6 and then left this
rook hanging on a one grabbing the
bishop on d5 allowing Queen take a1 and
then played Knight to c3 and it was a
very very sharp position which I know
usually suits race style but it may have
also been just a risky and somewhat
unsound decision given that black is not
material here and there's no way to
immediately trap the Queen the Queen is
always going to have the B to square
it's a difficult piece to attack so
going forward here ray did try and seek
some compensation targeting the f7 pawn
Bishop e7 d4 King b8 just doesn't seem
like that much for the exchange though
given that black is is slowly getting
the pieces into play I'm curious I guess
I've ripped e2 the Queen could escape
via a c1 so the Queen is still not
getting trapped in that situation so
Bishop f3 Bishop f6 and now it seems
like white is the one under pressure
given that there's there's some targets
there's some very clear target for black
on on d4 and it seems like that blacks
pieces are coming into play nicely
especially with with 96 on the horizon a
lot of game is over game just ended
let's a lot of moves there at the end
very quickly let's zoom forward here
that seems like Bach just held on to the
extra exchange after Queens got traded
there's a far less hope for white to get
any attack and King g2
I think a five as a last move kingi -
Ricky D eights and then a five yeah
already after Ricky d8 the position
seems quite hopeless given that the
Knights is pinned and attacked twice on
d2 Ray was going for some final tricks
actually really like this this last
trick that Ray played here looked to see
one cuz a lot of beginners would see a
free night and take a free night
Brook take T to looks attractive but
this would actually end the game in
White's favor given that and I take a
six it's actually a very aesthetic
checkmates combining the power of the
bishop
oh look and the Knights and all the
squares around the black king are
covered so it may be a final hope for
some kind of miracle but at at this
Grandmaster level players are not going
to be falling for checkmate in one
blenders at least just not yet and after
pawn 85 ray threw in the towel given
that there's no more 96 mates if if
Knight to c6 with a fork black could
just take on c6 and then take on d2 and
just be up a up at night in this
position with no compensation for whites
so tough game for Ray I think that puts
him at what point five out of the two
after withdraw yesterday and very good
start for URI cooze above so I don't
know too much about but I believe it's
his first time playing in st. Louis and
he's undefeated with we're wait a minute
did he how did he do yesterday he drew
right yes
so he is plus one right now woman how
other - 28 year-old Ukrainian we don't
know a lot about him yet yeah we have to
talk to him at some point in this event
if not today
so that is the first decisive game
that's the first game that's over
actually at all in Group A and I think
we've taken a glance we haven't looked
at Abruzzo
game yeah bruh zone against daro spirits
its Koopa vs Poland in Group A yeah
let's take a look at the current
position I'll just go back a few moves
and seem like why it was okay
temporarily up upon that rook takes e4
makes material equal but the first thing
that should jump out in this position is
the fact that white has the furthest
advance past pawn given this pawn on e6
is only two squares away from queening
Knight f4 check played chasing the King
away from potentially defending against
the past pawn and then we see rook to c7
perhaps attempting to chase the night
away so that the pawn can start rolling
and I don't immediately see what black
should do here think a couple more moves
have been played Knight a5 Pawnee 7 and
rookie for this looks incredibly
dangerous for black and I wouldn't be
surprised if White's just winning here
it seems like rookie for was not the
move that black wanted to play because
now White has a simple capture on d5 and
I can go up a pawn and with Knight 85 it
would defend the the e pawn prepare rook
c8 and EA Queen and just seems like Bach
is going down pretty hard here this
night is completely out of play if we
imagine Knight take t5 the knight on a 5
is completely dominated by the rook on
c7 and the King on h6 is out of play too
so I do admire the technique by bruising
is in this game too to take down his
pretty formidable opponent now I do want
to mention this is a matchup of webster
versus slough the cross sound collegiate
rivals darius weird sub course playing
for the st. Loup st. louis university
chess team and Lazaro bruised own is a
new student at Western University so I
wouldn't be surprised if these players
play many more games over the coming
months or years you know
have a tournament like this a few years
ago you'd have to fly a lot of people in
from around the country some
internationally and now because of the
local colleges and universities and the
scholarships and the teams it's amazing
that you know a lot of them are local
even though their Flags may say
otherwise
no it's great for st. Louis I mean I'm
it's hard to keep count of the number of
Grand Master's living in st. Louis
really hey there has to be at least what
between maybe 10 GM's per per college
and the additional number of GM's like
Eric Hanson and Fabiana Caruana there
has to be at least 30 GM's in st. Louis
I'm not mistaken but has to be one of
the most concentrated cities of
grandmasters
on this planet I would think it really
does we'll need to do some independent
research there hey look we have another
result in Group B action Chandra has
indeed won his game against Chris you
and ox is gonna be in a really good mood
after that when he gets on the board
after in unfortunate day for him
yesterday yeah we can see that there was
not much fight left for Christopher in
this game I mean the final position
basically says that all this King is
completely restricted white is going to
start a King walk just capture the sepal
and keep locking up the King and there's
no active active play for black in this
position so tough start for the
youngster Chris you losing the first two
games but it's a long event there's
seven more games to be played and at at
this level you just have to take it one
game at a time and just trying to
regroup for for the next game one of the
games we haven't taken a look at in a
little bit is Erik Hansen versus Alex
lunderman
in Group A and our Canadian friend is
maybe not too comfortable right now
Alex Lenderman is a longtime competitor
in the US Championship has been here for
if most of if not every u.s.
championship we've had here in st. Louis
no that's very true he's he's used to
playing in
st. Louis and I know he takes he takes
chest very very seriously I mean
recently coming from batumi he didn't
play any games but he was coaching the
u.s. olympia team I'm sure he spent
spent a lot of time delving into opening
preparation and sometimes this is a nice
situation to be in to be a coach for one
event and then a player for later events
and gets you informant and ready to
fight and we can see he's he's fighting
pretty hard in this game the combination
of Queen and Bishop eyeing down the
White King side which is quickly running
low on shelter and speaking running low
speaking of running low Eric Hanson's
time is just dropping below a minute
playing on that Ingram moves to play
until time control the last move let's
go back a little bit see what happened
ooh bishop take H 3 was a nice move to
to take advantage of this pawn over
worked on g2 and then Bishop d7 was
played a bit curious why White's time is
ticking here because it should be blacks
move let me update the board aha rook c2
played and now we see all of locked
pieces staring down against this g2 pawn
rook AAA check King h7 looks forced and
was played and I'm trying to see if
another move was played Bishop to e4
check and then everyone in there Bishop
f4 f5 seems like this bishop is shut out
and right white is just running out of
any sort of counter play and hands have
been shaken yeah this is just a
completely winning position the bishop
on e4 not only attacked but it's tied
down to the g2 pawn so Bishop takes c2
would just run into Queen takes you to
checkmate and otherwise I mean Bishop f3
runs into rook c1 so
tough game for Eric especially after a
nice one yesterday it's always easy to
keep up the momentum and and win game
after a game especially when you're
playing in such a strong field like this
right congratulations to Alex ligament
on that victory and let's see we have
had that a very important point I wanted
to make Eric and I can't know what it
was for the life of me I wish I could
help I'm sorry yeah I'm so sorry why did
I even bring it up you should not have
brought it up keep that in mind Oh see
DK on YouTube yes asking about the time
control guys if you want to know more
information about the format be sure to
check out us chess chance calm and you
can check out the forum at the embedded
video to the chess 24 console it's all
right there just click on live at US
chess champs calm 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves after they after black
hits that fortieth move both players
will have had 30 minutes added to their
clocks and then after that there's no
more extra time at it it's just 30
second increment from move number one
that's very true so there might be some
games that extend beyond the length of
this broadcast but there is a game that
is being requested in the twitch chats
by the username of the Kings gambit
saying that the hammer Dre of game looks
very interesting so let's go to that and
see how players unfolding when we last
saw this game White's King was quite
exposed in the center and it seems like
not much has changed in that regard and
now we can see the black Queen still
quite terrifying on d3 for whites now
both players are running low on time
with about five moves to play until the
extra time is added I really like
Locke's position I mean not only keen
safety but also the fact that Bach has
two knights
floor a rook whenever you have more
minor a couple of minor pieces for a
rook it can really help out when you're
the one attacking
because two pieces are quite often a
better combination in terms of attacking
than just one piece in this case I would
hope for black to to someday activate
the Knights trying to think of some idea
to get to get the Knights into play here
it is
this move is it king c1 was just played
me update the board here Oh Queen e4 was
played perhaps of peculiar retreating
move I think the idea of this move is to
actually guard the eight Foursquare
maybe there are some ideas of Knight a
four and if we can imagine black guests
the Knight to a4 black would be
attacking the rook but also threatening
the very nice Queen to e1 with the King
running very low on squares given the
knight would control B - the bishop
would control C 2 and this would just be
about not quite checkmate there would be
Queen d1 but it seems it was very
delicate for white - to hold on here so
both players sitting at the board and
you basically have to stay at the board
when you both players are low on time
and now it's up to White's to figure out
what to do I'm not seeing too much
counter play the black king is so safe
on G eights
this Bishop this appears to be doing
nothing I would like if I were if I were
white I would like to play something to
grab the initiative something aggressive
maybe like Queen Queen to b5 but
honestly this doesn't seem too useful
actually I'm realizing there would be a
nice response to Knight a for leaving
this Knights undefended wait go back one
moment I do want to show
well night-night a4 controls B - no Oh
Queen c2 checked me than one that's very
true so I was thinking of Queen e8 or
Queen ze1 Knights but Queen c2 is
as much more efficient so whites queen
is tied down to the sea to square and
with additional ideas of queenie one
that's not gonna be so fun for whites i
was thinking of some move like f for
guarding iman squares but there's also
the h1 square for black and there would
still be ideas of perhaps 9a for
attacking the rook and potential queen
each one threats so it seems just about
hopeless for hammer in this game right
we have any players down in the scene
there are studio door kind of rumbling
yeah that usually might be some people
locked out yeah so you know some players
get out of here I'm gonna I gotta go get
a sandwich or something I'm hungry that
happens
no hard feelings though one game that we
haven't looked at yet which I do on a
glance at it seems quite interesting as
the battle between Sergei Azara of and
Dennis Boros who I mean Dennis coming
off a Dennis lost yesterday tough game
to Al Shean how did it soar up to
yesterday Zara won his game he won his
game so yeah we really didn't pay that
game a lot of lip service but yeah he
didn't know hilarious so if we look at
the current position here we see blacks
last move let's go back a little bit
because it seemed like black had some
nice initiative starting from this
position with pawns he five attacking
the knight on d4 I do like the setup
that Dennis has employed here with both
rooks on the two the two center files
and as we see Queen techie for rooked a
key for Knight d5 rookie to a pig has
entered the the second ranked work on e
two targeting the bishop provoking
Bishop h4 where now that Bishop seems a
bit out of play
maybe there's ideas of g6 but black just
continues initiative bishop take i5 and
white has some issues to worry about the
C to pawn attacked twice by both the
bishop and the rook and perhaps not the
easiest pawn to defend we do see night
a3 was played and we update the game
here
Knight a3 pawn d4 very nicely fixing
these these Center pawns and simply
controlling more space you see King c1
perhaps planning rook t2j rook de8 rook
t2 is played and now Bishop to d6 and
blacks pieces are activating nicely
sometimes this is a power of the bishop
pair especially if the bishops can come
to useful center squares it can just
control so much area of the board and
White's pieces are just not well
coordinated I mean this Knights
completely out of play on a3 the bishop
out of play the rook out of play
and black already having massive threats
for example Bishop f4 it is a simple
threat to win material so a few more
moves have been played I mean it has to
trade that right give it or else the
rooks gonna be pinned okay he did so
let's see how this happened rook take
you to rook take e2 King d1 rook g2 so
Bacchus is maintaining some nice
domination rook e1 ideas of rook to e8
so g6 is played and now rookie -
sometimes when your opponent's rook is
on the second drink one of the best
strategies is to try and neutralize it
by putting your own work on the second
pink but black's rook clearly more
active in this position after rook e1
it's still a question how does black
make sufficient progress it seems like
at any time
black could just trade rooks and stack
the h3 pawn which would be going up upon
but maybe maybe black is looking for
more in the
position I would think that Dennis is
debating whether to trade on he won
right away or maybe repeat once go back
to e2 and then trade more moves been
played so smooth 30 on says move 36 but
I see that the additional time has been
added I would highly doubt that the
clocks are correct actually in this
position given that the players start
with 90 minutes and they only get an
additional half hour so the clocks can't
be right I don't know if we can zoom in
there if the camera resolution is high
enough to see the clock time might be
awfully dark you know
yeah DGT it's it's the closest thing the
perfect we have and sometimes those
clocks display a little time it's three
minutes and nine seconds okay yeah 55
seconds on on white three minutes on
black so they are they are actually
cooked in time trouble then if they're
still behind move 40 seems like white is
white the one thinking in this position
I see the rook is on G rook is on e too
so it seems like this well did occur it
says that black is on move here maybe
this isn't completely accurate the dgt
Board says if black is on move but the
clock shows that white so we'll see
what's going on here
yeah I'm a bit perplexed given that
whites I'm moving it looks like there's
a black rook on g2
so maybe what happened is Bishop take h3
was played yeah and now we see the
bishop on h3 and now the rooks are
getting traded so this is how Dennis
decided to win the pawn and this just
seems like a technical endgame black
being up upon this g5 pawn is a little
bit annoying because it clamps down on
the three King side pawns for black but
I mean it seems like at some point
blacks should go for King g7 h6 and then
just have two connected pastors on the
Kings side and actually excuse me if I
miscounted but black is actually have
two pawns in this position so I think
this game should be over relatively
shortly
seems like white doesn't have much
counter play Knight b5 was played what
expected bishop to be a here just keep
everything defended and a box should be
cruising to victory we have a couple of
results to report first of all in Group
B Jacobson and zerk have drawn their
game which is the only draw of either
field this round thus far in Group A
bruised own has defeated spirits and so
far as all decisive games there that is
Brazil's first victory after coming off
a defeat yesterday and so that puts him
back and he's got to be feeling good
after that one have do you have that
game handy yeah we can take a look how
it finish we did see earlier very strong
pawn for whites reaching isse Evan and
then after rookie for the simple moves
from white rook take a seven-night c4
[ __ ] has another pawn hanging here 98 d5
could be played rook a six was played
and then a nice obstructionist move
Knight to c6 obstructing the rook from
guarding a passed pawn and there's no
way that block in soft upon queening
position so very smooth finished by
Lazaro burrs own who did rebounds from
yesterday he lost a tough game - I
believe Draya yesterday so it's always
nice after losing a game where you can
immediately rebound and and beat a
strong player like this how important is
it to get off to a good start in a
tournament like this I think it's very
important I mean if you can if you can
get the momentum early on it can carry
you a far far away throughout so you
believe in momentum I do believe in
momentum I think I think it is a factor
maybe it's more psychological but I
think it's it can be even more important
like if you get off to a slow start that
you don't completely fall apart
but you're able to regroup move on from
the past and have acknowledged your
mistakes but don't let it get to you
psychologically because it's it's
happened before especially in these it's
kind of one day one game of day formats
where players will kind of have this
downward spiral effects that you don't
want to be sucked into that that
situation I'm hearing that Danish
barouche has won his game or at least
the game is over
if I don't know if we can get a shot of
the board maybe both players are already
out of the tournament Hall but as we
expected he was looking really good
against Sergey Azhar of and the
Hungarian player that we know very well
here in st. Louis boorish looks to have
won his game yeah it's still not on the
dgt board but I'm told the game is over
we still see the other white time
ticking yeah from from 90 minutes but
after Bishop b8 seems like white had
enough given that there's there's no
active play to clean pawns for black
number of ways for blacks that convert
this position e6 become King g7 King g7
h6 had come and yeah nice nice rebound
from from Denish given that he also lost
yesterday so this is what we like to see
you a lot of back and forth a lot of
decisive games and sometimes tournaments
at this high level you see a lot of
draws but that's not where what we're
seeing in the
events not at all man like you look at a
tournament like the Sinquefield cup
which is super strong and he brings into
this amazing viewership you're gonna see
a lot of draws this is not the place to
come if you're looking for draws and
you're probably not there's one game we
haven't looked at at all though Eric and
that is one that is still in progress in
group b conrad hold versus l run more
india body
let's take a look yeah i i this game was
not even under my radar maybe I was
looking earlier and they had some they
had some crazy position really crazy
position where White was down a piece
but but props had some strong attack I
do want to jump forward to the current
situation because a lot has happened
since then of course of viewers do want
to see the the full game you can check
it out in chess 24 or us chess champ
calm but let's go forward here to the
current position and right off the bat
I'm counting a lot of pawns for whites
White has six pawns in this position
black has four pawns but black does have
two pieces two minor pieces for a rook
so it's very imbalanced I'm not actually
sure who would be better in this
position I do want to say that when I
was first starting chess I had a my very
first chess coach told me something
which I didn't believe at first but over
time I I be I realized is is very true
is that whenever you have a rook for two
minor pieces the rook is the rook does
need to be accompanied by a few ponds to
level out the material balance so my
first coach told me that two minor
pieces is usually worth a rook into
pawns not a rook in one pawn which seems
a bit contradictory to the whole point
value system in chess two minor pieces
are six points rook and two pawns are
seven points but in many situations two
minor pieces working together against a
rook can be a lot more valuable
and that's why I'm not sure what's
exactly going on here because and in my
opinion material is about level and it
can sometimes come down to piece play
and who can better coordinate their
pieces and who can create passed pawns
because this is this is an endgame
situation black does have a passed pawn
on e6 not the most impressive passed
pawn and meanwhile White has two outside
pastors on g3 and h4 also not that
impressive so both players might be
looking to push at some some time soon
it is white to move now I don't think
the clock times are correct because they
are it just reached move 40 so we can
expect Conrad to have maybe just under
half hour left and he is thinking in
this position perhaps pondering how to
make progress here I mean some initial
ideas that I would look at I would
really like to start advancing as the
generator uh so we do see okay here's
about 25 minutes left the problem for a
white is you can't immediately advance
either pawn without losing upon this g4
loses h4 and h5 would lose upon an h5 so
white might have to work around this
maybe maybe try and find a way to
improve or if anyone perhaps some idea
of t1 check but I'm not sure if that
accomplishes too much another idea that
I would consider in this position looks
a bit odd but sometimes you have to be
creative in situations like this is to
put the rook on each one
rooks normally like to be behind pass
pawns and then put the King on g1 and
then maybe start advancing start with h5
and then G 4 seems a bit awkward for the
setup of the white rooks because usually
it looks like to be connected in the
endgame but this might be one way to
make progress
just push this King to h3 instead
King to h3 perhaps another way to make
progress let's go back a move King III
was played seems like his idea is to
play King g4 in order to support the
pawn in h5 and then maybe later play
rook h1 this might be an improved
version of what I was thinking because
he's using the King as a useful piece
rather than just a passive piece and I
don't immediately see how black will
will try and prevent this a move like
move like Bishop to h5 just runs into a
fork pawn pawn g4 should just be winning
a piece it's always nice when you have a
clear plan especially later in the game
and your opponent's might be the one
struggling to come up with ideas so I
mean just at a glance I would probably
pick white here just given that there's
a clear plan in the position and
whenever you have a plan involving
pushing pawns it can be it can be easier
to play so your what do you think here
this is still up in the air is I would
slightly prefer White's but I think it's
I I think it's gonna be a long game I
think both like all three results are
possible and I wouldn't be surprised of
this game goes much longer than we're
around to watch it for especially with
both players reaching time control
having an extra half-hour to to
calculate the the concrete variations
and the nuances so this could be one of
the longest games of the rounds between
both groups yeah this show goes till
about 5:00 p.m. Central time each day
now when we get into the later rounds if
there's game closures we're staying on
as long as we need to to see the ends
and to talk of the winners but we'll
probably probably won't see the end of
this game you're right in Group A there
are still two games in progress
and it looks like hammer and drave have
changed a little bit since the last time
we looked let's take a look at what has
happened since we saw the hammer all
seemingly in trouble yeah
my head hurts just looking at this
position it just seems like complete
chaos now but still seems quite
favorable for for the black side let's
go back a little bit we last left around
this moment after might be six rook c5
queen f1 yeah the Queen planted itself
on on d3 and then to e4 and this is
where we weren't quite sure what to do I
realize that the cry constant ideas of
traps Queen c2 of this Queen never moves
away we did see Queen to d1 perhaps
trying to maneuver the Queen to the
Kings side but this does allow Queen to
be one check and black wins a pawn so
black is now having a nice material
situation having having just two nights
for the rook and after Keaney one Queen
e6 check Queen e2 I think black
correctly avoids the Queen trade with
Bishop to e4 whenever you're not sure
whether to trade Queens you always want
to look at King safety in this case the
white king just so much less safe than
the black King so that really indicates
that black wants to keep Queens on the
board and now we see Bishop to c7 the
knight centralizes to the d5 square
maybe some ideas of I was gonna say 9a
for that the bishop is covering f4 but
the knight is hitting the bishop on c7
and then rather than moving the bishop
white plays a counter attacking move
pawn to f3 and yeah this was giving me
some headaches because there's just so
much going on here both sides might have
some concerns I mean this Bishop is now
attacked on e4 the bishop on c7 is still
hanging not to mention the Queen's are
aligned the rook is pressuring both
nights
I really don't know what to expect here
um it is blocked to move Andreyev has a
decent amount of time to try and
calculate and figure out what exactly is
going on there is one line that catches
my eye that if drea of captures on c7
and white takes on e4 black would not
want to trade Queens especially in this
position if the Queen's got traded then
um the dust is settling and black would
be left in a skew everywhere one night
is being lost in this position
so perhaps black could try something
else but seems like this is not what
black should go for a given that's okay
the Queen's are attacking each other and
and there's pressure on c6 so white is
already threatening to win a piece here
I just don't see a media defense for
black so that might rule out Knight take
c7 and then it's a question
what does black play I mean that the
position visually looks very good but
sometimes concretely there there could
be problems and I'm wondering if Trey
have overlooked f3 perhaps muddying the
waters and given that light was clearly
worse earlier I think this is a good
strategy from hammer to try and just
create chaos on the board
whenever you're worse it can be smart to
just create complications to try and
provoke your opponent to go wrong if
because of the f3 move is the bishop
forced to move Queens trade and then the
knight on c6 Hanks's right yeah that's a
that's a good point
I mean White has the clear throughout
here of taking the bishop and wherever
the bishop moves you're absolutely right
that the Queen's will get traded the
knight will be lost on c6 so then the
question becomes
does block have any source of
counterplay given that it seems like
night takes you seven doesn't work
moving the bishop anywhere it doesn't
work like for example Bishop f5 Queen 86
that should take you six then white is
probably the one playing for a win
sometimes you have to rely on process of
elimination
I'm not I'm not seeing anything
immediate oh there is one idea that I'm
seeing with some purpose of targeting
the rook on a c5 now I should point out
to everyone watching I'm not using any
engine here so it's difficult to jump to
any immediate conclusions but I'm sure
if you were is watching if you want like
a precise answer what's going on you can
go on to chess 24 and get an immediate
answer but from a human perspective I'm
seeing this loose rook on c5 I'm
realizing that any kind of normal move
for a block doesn't lead to anything so
that would allow me to consider some
move like Queen to g6 taking advantage
of some geometry across the board it
does leave the bishop hanging but it
eyes a g1 square and if I can get in
Queens II won the king and the rook on
c5 with the attacks and maybe this is
some line where okay the the pawn could
take Queen g1 the King moves Queen take
on c5 and blacks should be coming out on
top but now I'm wondering if Queen
captures on you four should also be okay
for black his Queen g1 and then King the
Queen comes back and black is holding on
to both Knights so
don't take my word for it but I would I
would probably be inclined to play queen
g6 here and or at least start
calculating queen g6 given that it does
make an immediate counter of threats and
I don't quite see what white is doing
from this position to counter Queen g1
so it seems like drea is uh
as entering the tank here he's he's
being been thinking for a while from
this position I'm sure if we have that
most accurate move time just updating
the board here so the last move was
played 16 minutes ago I'm not sure if
that's entirely correct but I mean I
would probably still prefer to be black
here given this Queen g6 resource but
we'll have to see what happens it
wouldn't surprise me though if it's been
16 minutes this is a big deal to think
about for good yeah and this is this is
move 41 so sometimes when you get that
additional time you just want some time
to settle down relax and and calculate
concretely he is reaching for the C pawn
that did not take a look at 63 us was
the top move suggested by the chest
24-inch toilets so you're using the
engine okay I'm just going so Knight
takes c3 was not under my radar and I'm
trying to figure out what's going on
here after the simple rook takes c3
the bishop still attacks
I would think I'm missing something here
at given that I mean there's well there
should be a clear purpose why Dre of is
allowing this bishop define Bishop d5
but white should be happy to win the
exchange or trade Queens and be up
exchange was in the position like this
probably pawn take would be bit safer
position like this black only has a
knight and a rook for a pawn which is
not much not much for being down the
exchange and in light would be clearly
pushing for a win I think we do see rook
takes c3 was played I'm very curious
here 94 Wow ah 94 these players are
having sharp our tactics and me clearly
why they're in the playing Hall Knight
d4 is a very aesthetically pleasing move
once you spot the kind of simple
tactical trick given that if Queen
taking 4 then there's my take f3 and the
Queen the White Queen would be lost in
this case if rook take f3 Queen taking 4
this is a very nice removal of the guard
tactic where the pawn defends the Queen
but the Queen's not defending the pawn
the pawn due to the pin so Knight take a
3 is just decisive in box favor so now
this begs a question after 94 where is
white going with the Queen and it seems
like okay black is temporarily down in
exchange but there are I mean there are
still a number of concerns given that
black house initiative the king is still
lacking shelter on a1 and it still seems
like drea should have things under
control at this point it looks
terrifying for white I mean that's me
1,600 in the room mm-hmm but I agree I
mean the Queen's attacked me maybe one
move his Queen Queen III there's a
knight take out three with check which
is a big problem best-case scenario
maybe you see yeah cuz that's a queen
leaves the e-file Queen really moves
anywhere s3 could still be taken with
check with discover check even by the
bishop so Queen III was played and the
night take f3 winning the pawn attacking
the King King f2 played quite quickly
and I mean I black should have full
compensation for for the material
deficits actually black has two pawns
for the exchange so I can't really call
it a material deficit and now it's just
a question how it's a further the attack
against the white king so we only have a
couple of minutes left
can we glance one last time and set two
verses of Kobe on let's do it that's the
only other game still in progress in
Group A I'm actually surprised that a
Cobian has been surviving for this long
because his position seems pretty dire
earlier but now we see he did activate
his rook now now he has a pig on the
second rank but white still has these
menacing King side pawns and these F and
G pawns should be running further down
the board very soon and this other rook
is shut out from e2 because a bishop is
controlling the e2 square and both
players have have received the extra
time a Cobian is below 10 minutes after
how they're gonna bond if there are
units push pawn g7 played
yeah I mean it seems just about hopeless
for lack given that okay the pawns are
going to keep pushing if rook to g2
there's simply at six
meanwhile black would like to figure out
some counter play on the kingside it's
some kind of mating idea involving the
night or the rook but there's nothing it
doesn't seem like there's anything to be
done here especially with this rook
unable to enter the game especially now
that it's tied down to defending the g8
square so yeah quite quite selfish in
each seven are king eight seven random a
seven yeah seems desperate
I mean he's hoping for some case where
maybe white would play a terrible move
like Bishop c4 and then after Knight
takes e4 B takes e4 rook to e2 and then
the game could switch switch gear is
given that okay now now Burke take a two
is coming an idea of King to a7 is the
whites not queening with check and this
might even be winning for black getting
threats but okay so theramin is not
going to play Bishop to c4 you still has
to make some progress maybe you know
just to move like rook f7 ideas of rook
f8 also ideas of f6 seems like it should
do the trick but at a point like this he
has so much time he's going to be
careful he knows he has advantage it's
just a matter of making sure
everything's under control
Black's not getting any counter play
it's exactly the situation he wants to
be in yeah while we can
and speculate on the result it does look
like it's gonna go past our curfew so if
we have results I'd like to see them so
far you know we've had a really exciting
day not just yesterday but today
especially right we've got another week
of this stuff this is gonna be amazing
this fall chess classic you can tell
it's fall because there's a pumpkin
anyway so let's take a look at the
results that we have today so far for a
group a and now we can speculate that
dre of he looks like he's still in
control and then set to is marching that
pond and that's one pond that Cobian
does not like to see pushed me it's not
fun when it's working against you that's
true I mean I would not have expected
five decisive gains in group a a
strongest group I mean in a field of all
players over 2600 you would think that
there would be a lot more draws and
decisive gains but it's not what we've
been seeing so far and I mean it just
adds to the excitement for for us and
for the fans as well it's remarkable and
now let's take a look at the results in
progress for Group B only one game still
in progress when we just looked at a
while ago hold and more idea body and a
lot of decisions here as well the I'll
tell you the eval right now has Holt as
much better +1 but we'll have to check
in on that tomorrow so that will do it
for this afternoon here in a good old
Midwest thank you for joining us at the
fall chess classic this show was
produced by the world's greatest
production B team Tammy had was the
streamer Eric Mosel is the show designer
Isaac Krantz is the graphics and audio
man and our technical director is Danny
Machuca we invite you to join us
tomorrow at 3:30 p.m. Central Time and
if you want to watch the games live from
the very start they start at 1 p.m. at
us chess champs calm so until tomorrow
he's Eric Rosen the best streamer ever
international master Eric Rosen argue
with that yeah
put you over I'm Ben Simon and until
tomorrow we say so long from the
show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you